this is bad
such a hassle oh thank the thousand wins
you're if i may ask envelope ew cut it
out
i cannot let my peers hear about this i
cannot seek help from anyone else
but you
please let us move to somewhere more
let's talk in the courtyard
what's with the sneakiness
[Music]
ugh
this place will do tell us what it's
about already
how should i begin oh right
let me tell you a secret first it's a
secret of my past
and i confide in you to keep it don't
worry
my lips are sealed as a matter of fact
my grandfather was a pirate oh
wait why do you sound so blithe do you
think i'm making it up
look at my eye patch i inherited it from
my grandfather
and this is solid proof that we are
related by blood
my how could you not know such common
knowledge
this is no different from children
inheriting their hairstyles from their
parents
yesterday i was glancing through the
notes my grandfather left
and stumbled upon records that spoke of
a treasure
treasure according to his notes
the treasure is buried in the lost
arcadian ruins
treasure but the location of the ruins
is currently unknown
i've tried searching for clues treasure
kyle what kind of treasure is it gold or
better yet
gems treasures that consist of nothing
but gold and gems are
third-rate treasures my grandfather's
treasure
is a sword a magic sword that grants the
wielder
unrivaled power oh wow
the sword was dropped from celestia into
the sea
by a god the moment he gripped the sword
thunder roared billows howled and the
clear skies were suddenly swallowed by
raging winds
with the might of the magic sword my
grandfather went on to defeat a hydra
a silver-haired banshee a wicked abyss
dragon
but the immense power of the sword
enticed
many more greedy pirates
to avoid meaningless conflicts my
grandfather hid
the magic sword these incredibly
thrilling adventures
are romances that could only be told by
pirates
holy moly that's just insane
a gang of treasure hoarders has been
very active lately
and many ruins have had their relics
stolen by them
i'm afraid that they will soon discover
the arcadian ruins
and the magic sword will be lost we
won't let it fall into the wrong hands
we must get the sword before them you
just rest assured that we are here to
help
wow great hey
so what you think isn't it exciting
we're talking well
let's go to the adventure the
adventurers should know more about the
ruins
we're not here for something that boring
we're looking for a sword that fell from
celestia
one that can kill eight-headed banshees
and silver-haired hydras
it's super mega uber powerful
it's fine as long as pymon doesn't tell
them the treasure's location
so cyrus do you know where the lost
arcadian ruins are supposed to be
arcadian thanks for your intel anyway
still no clues
well it's not like it's gonna be easy
come on
it's the hiding place of the super
amazing sword
anyway we should go meet up with kaia
first
yep oh you're back
do you have news for me listen we asked
around the avengers gildan found
what that much is expected why is that
oh i only mean that what's the fun in
finding it
without the hard work however i do have
some clues
i sent someone to collate black market
intel
it seems that someone does know about
the arcadian ruins
really where's the guy now now
as per the black market's rules they
will send someone to meet us to prevent
leaks
we will be meeting the informant at the
whispering woods
then what are we waiting here for
you have my thanks of course you'll be
compensated for your troubles
by the knights
this
um
that doesn't sound very good
ah
ah
ah look
why is this happening to me i shouldn't
have helped him
him who thanks so much for saving me
you're far more reliable than those
fuvonius guys
it's nothing she's a traveler she has to
do with stuff like this all the time
traveler i've heard stories about you
i didn't think i'd be saved by the one
i'm here to meet oh
[Laughter]
i didn't know how i could pay you people
in our circle know how important the
network
lucky but it's lucky for kion
listen well then the end three six armed
giants reside in the city in the lake
to guard the statue one the treasure
right
wait is that it there's also this map
that came with it
could this be the x first the spot
so the clue is more like a riddle well
should be a piece of cake for you
right well if you can't solve it i'll
leave you the intel
thanks via three six what does that mean
[Music]
okay
so
come take a look
i will make you better
[Music]
huh
both songs here
bye
so
huh
oh let me see what's inside she doesn't
love him at all
the passion rushing through the there's
another map
more pie mont's dizzy already hi
monolith
hello
[Music]
happy
so
huh
[Music]
[Music]
2
yes
uh
[Music]
mr giraffe always gets so drunk
up
huh
yes
so
yeah no worries
however you do it is fine
huh
oh
[Music]
ah
hip
ugh
ugh
this statue of the seven seems to be
affected by a monster nearby
defeating that monster might remove this
strange wind
current seal thingy around the statue of
the seven
ah
wow
huh
not so hard
huh
huh
[Music]
what
what
so
uh
cool it
cool
huh
huh
huh
dodge this
cool
it
ah
this time the mysteries have all been
solved
it sure took a lot of work but in all
fairness
this treasure map really is terrible it
looks like it was drawn by a pirate
so now
let's go for it don't want anyone like
like
anyways no you are nothing
but definitely not to become super mega
our kitty and trying
[Music]
huh
hmm
this must be the arcadian ruins is it
just me
or does it look plain oh
piemon gets it the perfect disguise is
always in plain sight
kaia's grandpa sure is impressive
oh nice uh it's no hurry the treasure is
waiting for us
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
oh don't push your luck
so
ah is this the end
where are you my treasure
let's look around i'll save you the
trouble
how about you let me take over
sharp eye but too slow i'm izzard
i thank you both on behalf of the
treasure hoarders
ah we've been keeping a low profile
you would be wise not to under it my
gang is just however
they're not i'm sorry to rain on your
parade
but your gang won't be participating in
your current plan
if you'd like to ask why you can go see
them
in monstab prison or perhaps you'd
prefer to join them permanently
the knights hey ikaya he wants to see
you oh
almost had it oh you mean the treasure
sorry but
you came all what no
treasure did i just say there isn't
it got me good a thief has no right to
criticize the methods of the knights of
wait what are you you're not gonna get
me
okay oh god what is this i didn't mean
it
what a troublemaker you
knight you're not gonna watch me die
hmm what an interesting suggestion
fine i'll confess and go quietly please
just help me
all right then guess i will have to do
some overtime work after all
bet you can't keep up with me
let it rain
bet you can't keep up with me
[Music]
ugh
yes
hey
[Music]
how embarrassing having my life saved by
a knight
don't forget what you promised hey is
this how the knights of fivonius treats
the people they catch
i'm sir yes sir uh captain should we
take these two in as well
of course not without them spreading our
fabricated intel
we wouldn't have been able to catch the
treasure hoarder
you're a bad man for lying to me shame
on the night
all right all right though the treasure
doesn't exist otherwise you would have
informed
let's go you did help me out this
is the triumphant harbinger of dawn that
points towards victory
if you don't mind i would like to
present you with this harbinger of dawn
as a reward harbinger of dawn
that's right it suits a well-cultured
and disciplined person
such as yourself wouldn't you say paimon
well if the reward is this harbinger of
dawn
you'd forgive me right i'm honored to
have such an understanding friend
yes yes you have my apologies for the
deception
i will not use the same method twice
what a surprise that you solved the
puzzles all by yourself
so it was you indeed however
even i believed the clues i was prepared
to quite impressive
ha that was nothing
no matter what you say i acknowledge you
but some people do
what a wonderful day now i have to go
interrogate my suspect
please excuse me do come visit me at our
headquarters
when you have the chance